so wonderful to be here especially with
our sandra or canadian girl
you do everything you're so good in this
show
what was it like for you to read a
script about a korean actress
dealing with a daughter who's adopted
her name juju and then the father and
the storyline of the korean family like
there's so much to it were you
overwhelmed
no
i was not overwhelmed it actually it is
the opposite it was excited and hungry
so i was really really ready to uh give
it my all you know amanda set up such a
beautiful world you know i mean
all those points that you us you already
mentioned and then in an academic
setting you know with different dynamics
with co-workers and budding romances um
and so it was just always overall
exciting to play
it was so good
amanda yes thank you amanda
where did this storyline come from
because you cover everything from racism
to sexism ageism talk to your level you
know dominant men to just women trying
to fight every single way they have to i
mean was this based on someone or an
experience
um i mean i think it's probably a bunch
of experiences all mushed together and
then um
once i started obsessing about sandra
which was quite early on in the writing
process i couldn't get over her i mean i
specifically communicate in a play
called stop kiss with jessica heck
and
um i hope it's okay that i'm going to
say this but i think um there are a lot
of actresses who can't play romance
they play at it but they can't
really
convey having a crush on someone in a
really
profound way and i always thought that
she was so beautiful as
in a romance and
um
also i couldn't think of anyone else who
could do a pratfall and also read as
someone with a phd in literature
so um
he was like the only person for me so it
was really i was just hell bent on
getting her
and
yeah
and it worked
and it worked
i just finished the last episode last
night and it really got me thinking the
chair represents so much more it
represents power the power of change
so what kind of changes would you like
to see happen in this industry
that's a big question honey yes i know
but well what is the change that you
would like to see in the industry
i mean in two seconds and uh i mean oh
gosh you need a whole day i know but
what what's that change you would make
we just need more women we need more
women of color we need more women and we
need
to change what's
considered you know
yeah and i would say it's really it's
really nice to be doing it
um
you know it's it's it's
the fact that amanda and i can keep
growing in our field and our profession
and be supported with opportunity and
and just the support for us to keep on
telling our stories you know i mean it's
like there are plenty enough
diverse people
who have stories to tell and can tell
them in a unique way
it's really the industry truly turning
towards those
um
who have
not been at the on the mainstream or
have been in charge in in those rooms to
to be supported to tell tell those
stories and i will also say this is
something that i really really believe
in um that there has just not been
enough development
yeah you know you have to you have to
build up your roster for someone who's
ready to take over and i think that we
just need to keep um
developing of those alternative voices
amen to that amanda thank you for
creating this story and sandra you are
just awesome thank you so much everybody
bye
you